now I'm no conspiracy theorist even
though I was the official resident
skeptic on a show on the very subject a
badge I wear with pride but this week my
skepticism went through the roof when it
was revealed that a major UK firm could
be considering microchipping employees
as part of an effort to boost security
and stop unauthorized staff accessing
sensitive areas in the words of that
fabulous female Poetry quartet vanilla
no way no way Mahna Mahna this is big
brother gone mad and I don't want any
part of it
research suggests that nearly half of
people are unhappy at work and it was
also revealed during this year's
national inclusion week that a quarter
of British workers feel discriminated
against with statistics like this
introducing this form of spying on
workers could lead to disaster last week
after argued that Alexa was sexist I'm
all worried that smart speakers are
actually nosey and that this
microchipping idea is even worse it's
time we all became a little bit more
cautious of intrusive tech I understand
your perspective and I understand why
many people would be concerned and I
think when I knew that was debating this
my initial reaction was also a concern
but then I start to think about it
slightly differently and my thinking is
kind of moved on so you presented this
scenario as very much as micro you know
horrible company's microchipping their
employees in order to breach that video
and control them I don't really see it
in that way so when you look at what's
happening with these chips it's very
similar technology to contactless cards
most of us I think it's like 52% or
something of transactions in stores now
are done contactless so what that's
doing is it's an if you look in Sweden
for example I think there's about 4,000
people in Sweden that have opted to have
these chips implanted in them and
companies in Sweden are almost offering
this as like a free perk because if you
think about it we carry around with
contactless cards we have telephones we
have our keys and we carry our trinsic
it's all of these kind of things that we
are wandering around carrying with us so
it's not a massive leap to imagine then
that if you want it and the emphasis on
the word wanted because do I ever think
a business should be clumping you down
in the line and stapling you with the
chip as you pass through no I don't and
that thought fills me with dread but if
you choose as an individual that
actually for convenience reasons yeah I
don't mind having my contactless chip
here and I'll just do this and it'll
replace my keys or my contactless
payments all my access my way no way I'm
reuse about 10 years ago I invented this
thing called eu-tech right and what it
was I recognized that sometimes in
accidents or you know when people can't
speak for themselves because I've been
knocked unconscious or whatever there's
a necessity for the mergency services
who come across these people whoever
comes to know who they are and what they
want what they need do into by the old
special medication you know is there an
emergency phone number for these people
bla bla bla bla bla so I invented the
Finkle the you tag and you wore ID
around your neck or on your wrist okay
and if you were picked up with him Oh
scooped off the floor with the emergency
service so they could plug it into a
computer pump a screen came up and all
the stuff that you would tell them if
you were conscious was on that screen
alright that's probably a good thing
okay
where I worry about what these chips is
if it starts controlling my car or it
starts out with my front door because
then I'm the old criminal now go where's
your chip nothing right I love that and
I mean that I know so just to quickly
pick up on both of your points at the
end of the day you're you tag is
different you're you tag is a device you
wear exactly I do not want a chip in
myself and the thing is look at this
back to those statistics half of all
people are unhappy at work a lot of most
people don't get on with their line
managers and people that are above them
in the workplace a quarter of people
feel discriminated against in the
workplace my issue is who controls the
the area that actually this data is
transmitted to pretty and how that can
be manipulated if it's a choice because
you said sorry imagine anyone Quinn you
said I don't want that if you don't want
that then surely that should be fine if
he or she is lazy here we don't care
period on the note choice I want to come
to that cuz I've got something to say
but let's just have a look at what buy
acts International which is a company
that actually as these chips says about
their own chips it says buyer hacks is a
passive near-field communications device
it does not contain a battery tracking
systems or any GPS enablement the buyer
haxe install enables the carrier to
increase their security in the digital
world we've accomplished to assist the
Swedish national rail system to enable
the buyer hacks install as a replacement
for paper tickets and plastic Travelcard
zone I'd like to draw your attention
folks to the following word in that
statement that I just read it does not
contain a battery for enough tracking
system so far so good
or any GPS enablement now normally the
world the word enablement is used in
tech to suggest that you could enable it
now here's that here's this back to your
question right so we all recall the data
Facebook breaches now all of us
voluntarily signed up to Facebook it was
voluntary back to your keyword they're
voluntary what we didn't sign up to was
knowledge that Cambridge analytical
would use that data to say for example
enable a political candidate we may or
may not have supported yeah and so I
think questions around privacy and data
coming no security safety how much data
these chips would contain now so I think
that's why it does need to be legislated
for because of course we all know of
course and Facebook's latest revelations
that they hired a firm to look into say
blame George Soros I think this takes us
into territory from my mind of why on
earth day we have ID cards I mean if
we're going to have chips implanted in
our body that give so much data that
track our movements and they both pay
contactless how do we had ID cards back
in 2008 we probably wouldn't be leaving
the EU because we would know who was
coming into the country who was coming
at leaving the country
you could swipe your passport in a night
and there wouldn't have been this crisis
over uncontrolled immigration which was
understandable on your chip device idea
let's hear from somebody who really
thinks it's bad idea but I wouldn't go
so first
legislate against it myself I'm a
wait-and-see person if the IANA
situation you need to give up a
microchip under duress you're beyond the
you have very little options available
to you this is gonna be as listen to be
as problematic is you can't lend your
microchip to a colleague to as awful as
criminal had holy ransom gathers out the
chips out of your body and demands
access to your company's place of work
all because you have a chip implanted
yeah I mean that is really worse cases
dystopian yeah totally and also the end
of day we do not spend all of our time
at work so why do I want a device from
work that's in me 24 hours a day 7 days
a week cut the cares why would you want
that and if you don't want that then
don't have it the bad days point because
you might be signing up for one thing
but that divides Micro everybody to do
it no I don't have one but I have it I
have no I don't have one in my left hand
that I've had yeah that I'm gonna be
walking but this guy does look off he
goes into his first door in his office
this is about the size of a grain of
rice by the way this on his hand or
because it is rich no it's kind of
between the thumb and finger look they
go any girls no messing around and its
wife saying by the way that one of the
company is one of the leading companies
was actually established by a former
professional body piercer so what makes
me laugh is the fact that so many people
are repulsed by having stuff but then
people get metal in them and all I can
say okay I can see some arguments for
and some arguments against but I think
what we all agree with is if a chip goes
in my body is followed by a piece of
fish all right